one of the things that's been hard for
me over the last three or four years is
i've got a lot of momentum going
and i don't like the cheering as much as
the buoy gary i mean
this is like the best interview i've
ever had yes
[Music]
the garyvee audio experience
hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk super
excited about today's episode on the
podcast we have an absolute force of
nature somebody who's uh caught the
attention of so many out there uh julie
hart is with us we're gonna get to know
her a little bit and uh
talk about some themes uh
for all the people who are listening
that um
you know are not aware of you why don't
you take the floor and give them a
little three four minute two minute
context point and then we'll get into
some questions
certainly so my name is julia hart i
have a show on netflix called my
unorthodox life
that follows me and my family as i
navigate the business world and of
course the interpersonal relationships
in my family um i have a bit of a
strange backstory i was brought up in a
very fundamentalist ultra-orthodox
uh
version of judaism married off at 19 to
a guy i met for a few hours no education
no connection to the outside world i
left when i was 43 years old
my children
and uh
a few months after i left i started a
shoe brand a year later we were being
sold in 17 countries a year after that i
co-branded with la perla a year after
that i became creative director of la
for a lot and two years later i took
over elite world group and am now
co-owner and ceo
and am transforming it have transformed
it into a talent media conglomerate
when i hear that and from the day you
started the shoe company to right now
just so i want to context that one more
time how many years has that been
started in 2013
became creative director of la perla in
2016 and in 2019 became co-owner and ceo
of the leadwell group so it's been eight
years
yeah so i think that's the most fun
question just knowing the ambition
and the makeup of this audience
what
what do you equate
what what natural dna
what things did you learn
what
how does one go from
that
scenario in an eight-year period to this
place where you're at
you obviously know yourself the best you
know at some level like what stands out
to you
that maybe isn't obvious right i mean
obviously ambition and tenacity and
there's going to be some things in there
that is there anything that really
stands out to you as like how you got so
far so fast in such a short period of
time especially given the context point
that you came from
i would say there's two things that i
think
without which you cannot really
dominate or change an industry or be an
uh an impotent change number one is
people my age become very proud of what
they know
as opposed to very proud of what they're
learning or their capacity to learn and
grow and that to me is one of my
greatest strengths i consider myself an
eternal student i am a researcher by
nature i love data so when before i came
into the industry i studied the industry
in fact i saw what was wrong and so
instead of learning from my own mistakes
i was able to learn from the mistakes of
others
and you know i recall i call ours this
company the british fleet right as
opposed to the spanish armada because
we're maneuverable and as you know very
well our industry is not just hesitant
to change it's almost immune and
allergic to change right because there's
this very entrenched fashion elite that
don't relinquish their power
but with the advent of social media it
is vastly democratized fashion whether
you like it or not because for the first
time the audience isn't with the
magazine or with the creative director
or with the photographer the audience is
with the talent
and so what has stood me in great stead
is that number one i research i educate
myself i never think that i have all the
answers and so i ask all the questions
what i've seen
can i jump in on that
yeah i think i'm i'm so aligned with
that
um
and i i mean i really associate with
that but let me ask you a nuanced
question that might help somebody tap in
who's listening because that's my
obsession of this podcast
do you think you're curious
because it's one thing to say
i'm data driven right because i want to
break down two things one curiosity from
eternal learner because i think there's
a nuance there and number two
there's a nuance of
um data that's black and white in
numbers
and then data that i live in that i'm
already sensing that you live in which
is it's gray and you're interpreting the
qualitative thing
not necessarily the quantitative thing
can you break that down perfectly stated
so
as you say i think that is part of being
an eternal student is seeing what can be
not what is it is utilizing the data and
knowledge that is available today to
predict what will happen tomorrow
so in 2019 for example when i took over
elite wall group and i said the talent
is the media
forget about the runway it's not just
about the runway i don't care if you're
a deep sea dive or a mountain climber if
you have an audience that comes to you
for aspiration or inspiration
i monetize that and so
thinking that way
is exactly as you said it is utilizing
data that is currently available to
everyone but extrapolating build on it
seeing what can be as opposed to what is
it also to your point earlier the
industry was run by people who always
relied on somebody else for distribution
whether it was a magazine or a runway
the nature of where we live today is the
human has the distribution and that's
about to be
compounded in a crazy way with web 3 and
decentralized blockchains and nfts
social was just the preview to a much
more
economic ice hundred percent yeah and i
love it and i think
it gives me the opportunity to literally
create an army financially independent
women because now the ball's in the
airport they've got the power because
they bring the audience
so we really brought in-house all the
areas of expertise production just
marketing uh content creation
you know think about what makes an nbc
an nbc right you have to have writers
producers directors photographers
content creators just because you're a
baseball player or a tennis player or a
singer or a model doesn't mean you can
create your own compelling content so we
brought that all in-house to truly
transform our talents digital presence
into networks
and
we then found that we have a viewership
of two billion people two billion people
we have data for two billion people we
have their buying their buying uh habits
we have their psychographics and their
demographics because again the talent
has the audience and so we can utilize
that to
target with such specificity that for
the first time an ad spend becomes
working dollar because it's trackable
and quantifiable and measurable
so on the talent side we help build them
and give them longevity in their careers
because we all know that there is a day
when you can't play tennis anymore when
you're not walking the runway when
you're not the polo player or the
football player because
age hits us all whether we like it or
not so this is the way to
elongate everyone's career by utilizing
the time that they're in the world's eye
to build them into a brand and network
so that people become so accustomed to
going to them for advice for inspiration
for knowledge and health wellness beauty
lifestyle you name it
that even once you run away anymore
they're still making money they're still
selling product because they're on
network julie how much effort is the
organization putting towards making sure
that people don't fall in love with the
platform of the moment you know i think
one thing that you mentioned earlier
about the end is right yeah i figured
you would like this one
yeah because i'm just listening to you
and so i'm like okay right exactly what
you saw with the old guard understanding
it's been fascinating for me to see even
in a seven year window
people that built their entire career by
being right that instagram was the
emerging thing from facebook
struggled in the last three years going
to tick tock because people get very
cozy in the thing they figured out and
is working for them and as you can
imagine let's talk about models to your
point that you're talking about tick
tock is a very different platform than
just putting up a photo on instagram so
the mediums change and the skill sets
and some of the people that naturally
over index on them have to adjust to
those new realities
gary i mean this is like the best
interview i've ever had yes
so
like 100 correct so what's really
interesting is in addition to being able
to transform talent into media we were
also able to
uh
massively expand our client and talent
roster so for the first time we're not
just you know we had i think we
represented 3 300 models when i took
over in 2019. we now have over 5400
talent so whether it's a runway or a
mountain it's irrelevant as you said
whether you're a model or a tennis
player or a deep-sea diver you need
attitude you need to be interesting
because digital enables you to just show
not what you're an expert in but your
nature your personality your creativity
and so
it is a very different kind of talent
even if it's a model it's a model who
has something to say
for the first and believe me these women
that we represent they have so much to
say
it's so annoying when people think like
put people into pigeon holes and say
you're pretty so you're not smart or
you're an athlete so you're an idiot
like it's terrible it's ridiculous and
you know we have we just signed someone
who has a
doctorate in uh macroeconomics i mean
this is what it's about it's about truly
giving them
and as you said gary how much we
invested in this the reality is
that
we needed to bring in all that expertise
in-house of course if you didn't control
that you were finished exactly let me
jump to a couple things because we don't
have a ton of time and there's a couple
things that i think you can so your
story
you know that is a that is a hardcore
community you know i'm an east coast guy
i was born in the soviet union to a
jewish family so i have a lot of
understanding
yeah
right yeah what's that
i was born in moscow oh i didn't know
that i was born in belarus that's crazy
i came when i was three and a half
i was three when i left russia and five
when i got here that's amazing so we
have very similar backgrounds so
so knowing a little bit more maybe than
the average 330 million american
not that everybody comes from
that pocket but a lot of people come
from their pockets native americans uh
the streets a drug three generations of
drug family uh
surfer dude who wants to be this or or
wyoming who wants to own new york or new
yorker that wants to just be in vermont
people come from their cultures
your story on paper that's why i'm so
excited to go deeper
how long did the seed
in your mind grow from
at some point in my life i'm not going
gonna live in these four walls that were
created for me how long was that
momentum because i think when you hear
an inspirational story like this for a
lot of people
i think a lot of people
i like uh one thing i do do with my
content all the time is i talk about
patience because i think people have a
bad relationship with time and it [ __ ]
them up right
they see your story and i'm sure
you know i know
because i'm living in life and i know
how many people have associated with
your story they might be in a tough
marriage there could be a million things
golden handcuffs right golden handcuffs
and a job
i think where peop people get
discouraged as they think that you did
it in like one day and they that's not
how human nature works i'm really
curious
in your own words how long was that
festering
to finally then get you to the point
where you were able to do it
so i have a book coming out it's called
brazen uh it's up for pre-sale on barnes
noble on amazon right now once they come
out it comes out in march
um and that really takes you through the
entire thing
i'm
ridiculously honest
i say all the mistakes that i made
because again it was literally
walking 300 years into the future it was
a world i did not recognize at all you
mean you mean when you kind of came out
of the cocoon at 43 like what is this
universe
literally talking about before you go
there i'm just like i'm so fascinated
you get there so uh so the trajectory of
that was
that
when i was 35 years old
that's the day i remember the day very
clearly is the day that i give myself
permission
to acknowledge that the system was
broken okay
because until i was 35
i thought something was inherently wrong
with me because everyone around me is
happy everyone around me fine just being
wives and mothers and you know
you're brought up thinking that your
only choices are good marriage bad
marriage right that's it because just
the minute you're born a woman your
entire life is already decided for you
your purpose in life is decided for you
because all women are supposed to be
doing the same thing
and the my nature was in direct
contrast i was told i was being that i
had to be to be a good person you're
supposed to be quiet humble behind the
scenes who who who in your family
gave you a glimmer of hope as you were
getting older did any of your parents
siblings other relatives or a friend who
or maybe the outside world who gave you
a little bit of you know you have your
insular part
which it was your own being that got you
there but there always is some enabling
to that did anybody who who my daughter
your daughter my daughter interesting
when um when she was five years old and
that's what really started this all my
entire life from the time i went into
that community until the day i left i
was miserable
when did you go into that community uh
when i when we we became religious when
i was
uh seven years old
so you come to america a couple years in
and you know because you got here when
you were five so two years in your
parents i guess your dad your mother
your parents said we're going further
down this hall of our religion we're
going to the this much more aggressive
version of it where that these are the
new rules correct and then
muncie when i was 11 years old so we
were living in austin texas at the time
you know and i was starting to cover
myself the whole nine yards and then we
moved because it wasn't religious enough
there sure
now
my daughter miriam turns five years old
and she is this
this little rebel uh she's the youngest
teacher in stanford history just to give
you an idea of who this young woman is
when she was a
um
a freshman in stanford she was also
giving a class on augmented reality
uh now if i hadn't left she would be
married pregnant with baby number two in
the kitchen and she's bisexual and as a
girlfriend certainly that would not fly
in my world either
so when she was five she started asking
all the questions that i've been
thinking my entire life except
why
so it was the first time where
you know they had convinced me that i
was bad they couldn't convince me that
my five-year-old was because i'd never
said those things out loud and she's a
massive sports person she won um
what's it called that ray spartan in san
francisco not just for women but for
women in general not just her age group
i mean she's an athlete and she was told
no you can't play sports you can't run
you can't do this you can't do that and
she would say why
and my husband would say so that a man
shouldn't have bad thoughts about you
and she would literally look at him and
say
but why isn't that his problem
and i was like yeah
wait a minute why isn't it his problem
and so it's really my daughter that's
because they were they were your natural
feelings that went into a box and it was
your daughter who reopened that box and
used to be on the permission to open
that box
it took me eight years eight years till
i actually walked out there got it so
right so to your point and by the way
everybody who's listening i you know
when i saw this come through and they're
like julia once again i was like yes
because of this exact moment this was it
for me and all of you are listening you
know me i think
you know we're around the same age like
i don't know i think i have 40 [ __ ]
crazy productive massive offensive years
in front of me i think people really
struggle with that and so when i hear
eight years from julia i'm like oh
literally my brain julia just went oh
not too much not too bad right whereas i
know
95 of my audience is like eight days is
like why didn't this happen why did i
get it like there's a complete lack of
understanding so for me
i just know that there's hundreds of
thousands of people that are going to
listen to this that are not happy
and they know subconsciously or
consciously why
and if i could just get them to start
during this podcast for an eight year
journey to do it and then they'll be 27
39 52 61 and then enjoy the rest of
their life
well that's uh
a mitzvah
you know and so i i'm pumped to hear
that and i think a lot of people needed
to hear that and thank you for that
talk to me about
something else that i think a lot of
people are going through as they get
more internet famous and obviously
the show has been a smash so you you and
the family are going through a
transition where a lot more people know
who you guys are and obviously it's
covid so it's not like
in the past where you're like always out
and about everybody's out about so it's
probably tempered a little bit and it's
but it's there and
what has been the most challenging thing
now that a lot more people know you and
your family from your perspective
i think what people don't realize about
me is i'm really a private person
and of course
but i am more
focused and driven than i am concerned
about my own
personal
preferences right so to me
what i realized is with the advent of
social media with the fact that that
talent people have the audience if i
want to change the world if i want to
i gotta be on it that's it
and so even though it's
really uncomfortable for me i have that
meaning you go out to dinner and now
people are rolling up on you and that
doesn't come natural no not even holy
and and i'm still in the phase do you
have this so what absolutely works for
me is no matter and by the way that's
why i was smiling again and we do have a
lot of similarities i'm so out and about
but i'm inherently private too and i
think it's a little bit to do with our
culture too forget about even
you know we were brought up by soviet
parents obviously your family made a
decision on religion was very different
than mine but i was still very taught
like everything is in the house nobody
knows anything outside that was a very
soviet thing right um
but for me the thing that makes it
palpable is i'm so flattered
i still am so flattered and grateful
that somebody wants to that it kind of
trumps everything else how about for you
what make what makes is you are you
saying your ambition
is what makes it palpable
i think it's the response that makes it
palpable you know um we have received my
daughters and my i mean we've received
literally hundreds of thousands of
messages from women all over the world
i've had twice where someone comes up to
the table that i'm eating it and hands
me a hand written level yeah and one of
those
this woman literally wrote that the day
that the show came out she was planning
on committing suicide
and
someone was talking about the show and
she said you know what let me just watch
an episode and
she didn't commit suicide no i know and
it makes it all worth
what makes it
the point of this show as you said it
doesn't matter whether it's golden
handcuffs or a bad marriage or a bad
community or just that you've been put
down your whole life yeah you've been
told to be polite or wait your turn
you know somebody asked me about the
show and i've caught some episodes i
said it's a parenting show
that was literally my answer to to your
point that you're making now almost
you know it is a stunning high
percentage of the world
that has at least one parent that plays
defense
yeah
and and then thus they understand yeah
absolutely absolutely and you know
when i think about why we did this and
honestly i think this is a great prep
for my book because the book goes really
in depth into
my psyche what i what i lived through to
get to where i am because as you said
who was it that said oh i became a
billionaire overnight it only took 30
years yeah
i'm not sure who it is but of course but
that's what it is and and i think it's
important for people to recognize that
and think and understand that
you are going to make a thousand
mistakes get comfortable with being
uncomfortable just
forget about what you do well i don't
would it would it wouldn't one you know
it's funny i always say adversity is the
foundation of success
i was i lost so much as a kid
you know
from where i came from that by the time
i was ready to go like business was
always easy for me because i loved no i
would argue that
you knowing even if you know at some
point it was conscious then it became
your subconscious then your daughter
brought it back to your conscious like
you were in such a [ __ ] no
environment that by the time business
was easy for you oh yeah it was amazing
i love it it's all i want to do like i
came out i tried the whole club bar
thing and i was like
do that i just want to work i want to
show the world what i have inside of me
that's all i care about and so
i got focused because i didn't know but
you know it looked fabulous on
television and then i found out hey in
clubs nobody actually dances what's the
point they all look at each other i
don't know
i
genuinely still don't understand it so
to me
what drives me what excites me what
keeps me up till two o'clock in the
morning and back up at 4am because i am
a insane insomnia
is the fact that we can change things we
can have it how do you think how do you
think the kids are handling the extra
thing oh my god they're having the time
of their lives you know i'm sitting ah
they're like this is amazing we can get
into anywhere we want to go
not having the time of their life mama
over here is like all right
talk to me about your now look so a
little bit of fun before we get out of
here social media what platform comes
most natural to you which one do you
personally just like
oh actually gary i'm glad that you asked
that because i never answered your
platform questions okay go ahead do
yourself actually because it's actually
very interesting the beauty of our
talent is that they're platform agnostic
right people still haven't realized is
the talent is the platform that's right
so whatever attention attention is the
only
that's the
asset that's the commodity the command
the attention correct and with that
commodity you can also have
targeting
roi on on your advertising spend you can
literally change the narrative and so
what we found is wherever our target
where let's say for example tick-tock
right when talk came out it became
really big through coved what people
don't realize is that we did a deal with
tick-tock they helped us
with our elite model look and we brought
our talent on to tiptop
and the talent brings the audience so
we're actually platform agnostic there
could be 900 more platforms it doesn't
matter my talent is the platform of
course and we're going to put the power
in their hands so that they can be i
just want an army of financially
independent women that's the goal that's
not an oily appliance women
a predominant amount is we do represent
men well and we have wonderful agents
who represent themselves um
you know it's really funny one of my fun
questions
and obviously you have this smash on one
of the platforms what about your
consumption on ott are there any shows
that you watch obviously you're grinding
and focus but you know i use new york
jets football and the mix that's my
escapism every human needs an outlet is
it reading is it podcasts
is it shows documentaries that's how i
learned like
where do you cons what do you consume
when you consume so i'm a voracious
reader i love to read to me
books were my eye to the outside world i
wouldn't be where i am today if i did
not read everything i could get my hands
on when i left atlanta i lived in
atlanta for a while long story when i
donated my
books to the atlanta public library and
i was told then that it was the largest
donation in the last industry and it's
just books are you are you one at a time
or you got five going and continuing
i am a serial monogamous darling
i love that what about um what about
podcasts i do like television but you
know again i'm a big netflix an amazon
consumer
i love um
i love escapists right so it's always
the shows i generally watch are either
historic in nature documentary or female
empowering you know i love shows where
you know women rule yeah and it just it
gives you all the sense of the world
so exactly so like i'll watch something
like a blizzard
because that's how i grew up minus the
parties in the fabulous clothing yes
woman's house to you know father's house
to husband's house women's minds are not
made for intellect or politics or
business just be a good wife
so i watch those shows because it
reminds me where i come from yes and
i'll watch shows about female
entrepreneurs how how how is the
establishment of your community the old
guard reacting to you right now is is
this like a problem
deliciously darling
you love what it's doing right
well you know what it is
i'm very careful because it isn't about
any people it isn't about a religion it
isn't about
bad versus good happy versus unhappy
the rule that exists in my world existed
globally around the world a couple of
years ago
just the fundamentalist communities
whether it's jewish fundamentalism
muslim fundamentalism
look at any funny yeah look at those
things coming out of of afghanistan
right of course
or as you said whether it's just an
unhappy marriage or someone who's ex
that's right the stuff the most the
stuff that's most extreme all of us can
be like oh that's some extreme [ __ ] the
party that i work on every day is like
if you are hanging around pessimistic
people
you're going to be affected and and
unfortunately you know i get a lot of
rads doing you so you all understand
this i go very extreme with it because
i'm trying to like [ __ ] help i'm like
look
if your [ __ ] mom is putting you down
all the time and is pessimistic you have
to limit your time with your mom and
people the comments are always like
even your mom i'm like yes your [ __ ]
mom your mom is the [ __ ] problem
yeah i mean i always say you know there
is it says in the torah
code which means your life comes first
period
your life comes first and
what people understand is uh in hebrew
the word for influence is hashba
and our spa comes from the root which is
shipoo which means a slam right
it's like
and
the other thing that i would say to your
point gary which is very very great
point is you've got to have so much
internal
internal confidence that you don't hear
the naysayers when we started
transforming this company from talent
management to talent is media everyone
told me i was crazy
something that um what's your name
gertrude stein once said when asked
about uh how people react to seeing uh
you know because she was like basically
considered the mo the mother of um
impressionism and so people would see
the impressionist painting in her
apartment for the first time and when
asked what the reaction was she said a
line which to me is the core of
everything i do
they come to mock
what they say
but they say pray
ignore the mockers forget it they're all
going to come and mock if you're doing
something different if you are a
a lightning change
everyone's going to mock you get used to
it get used to being mob you know you
know what's funny about that
you're an idiot a crazy person but then
they stay to pray because then
they see that what you're doing is right
you know what's really funny i got to
such a extreme version of that
that
i even think i subconsciously
reinforce the booing i call it booing
i am obsessed with it me too
i i actually
only want to be the underdog only like
one of the things that's been hard for
me over the last three four years is
i've got a lot of momentum going
and
i don't like the cheering as much as the
buoy
not only am i comfortable with it to
your point that's the right statement if
people could get uncut could get
comfortable with the no and the pushback
life gets so much better
where it where it gets really
interesting and fun is when you're
addicted to the bullying
i mean i i my great preference because i
i always innovate in everything i ever
do so immediately it's no
oh yes
everyone looks at you like you're crazy
when i change the way that like stretch
was incorporated so we could make
stretchy chiffons or stretchy lace
a guy patted me on the head
literally with his hand yes oh julia i
don't think
i mean
i know i know well i hate the
establishment it's crazy how much of the
stain i have for the establishment
nothing makes me happier i think that's
what absolutely associated me to what i
was seeing
in your episodes i'm like uh-huh i'm
like i understand that super duper and
it tastes so [ __ ] good it tastes
great and you know you say you're
addicted to booing i call it i'm
addicted to fear
i try to do something that scares the
[ __ ] out of me at least once a week yeah
you're pushing yourself you challenge
yourself you push yourself you know it's
funny fear
yeah fear is one of the biggest things
that i try to eliminate you know you're
pushing yourself that's a different
version of it to me a lot of people
don't think things do things because
you're scared
and i and people use fear as a weapon as
you know
i mean that's exactly what it's my own
personal weapon i totally
tell me i'm crazy it literally makes me
feel good
that's that's when you just know
you're more right than the masses
hey they come to mock but we stay to
pray that's a really cute saying anyway
listen thank you so much for being
give us party shots where can people
find you
what you know obviously have a book
coming out that's on amazon and pre-sale
yeah let's just mention the netflix show
on your socials anything else where can
people find you to continue this combo
that i mean any of my socials instagram
tick tock um you know i'm going to be on
a lot of more net you know podcasts so
forth and so on
you know and people have been reaching
out to me and i just hope they continue
to do so and
you know let's change the world
congratulations on everything
thank you it was great to meet you and
by the way congratulations on everything
you've accomplished
you're you're a badass like full-on
youtube botcha what's up it's garyvee
first of all thank you so much i hope
you're doing super well during these
times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this
is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you